I love deadlines I like the whooshing
sound they make as they rush past so Big
Finish review this one's actually a
patreon commissioned one because while I
have been doing Big Finish reviews
regularly I'm you know more or less sort
of jumping around occasionally I will
have a vote from the various people on
patreon to various people there my
patronize errs yeah I know them by name
I stick them in the credits at the end
that's one of the benefits to a plug
anyways yeah so normally I just give a
list of Big Finish things that I have
already gotten my hands on either cuz
they were on sale or they were gifted to
me and I let them choose now I had a
patreon Iser who had a very specific
story he wanted me to check out and he
actually commissioned a review and so I
have now listened to Doctor Who unbound
deadlines and this is so this is so
weird it's it's written by Robert
Sherman who has written my favorite Big
Finish stuff so far
quite easily in fact he wrote Jubilee he
wrote um a Holy Terror which is still my
favorite hero chimes of midnight like
he's really really good at writing
Doctor Who and writing Doctor Who for
audio now Doctor Who unbound is a bit of
a weird beast so it's essentially a
series of hour-long what-if stories
completely removed from Doctor Who
continuity and in fact with actors who
have never played the doctor before
taking on whatever iteration of the
doctor the various writers came up with
now what Robert Sherman decided to
tackle was what if Doctor Who never
actually got produced as a TV series
like it was
conceived it was worked on never
actually went to air
that's his what if so this story largely
centers around a aging writer man named
Martin who is in a nursing home and he
is voiced by the incomparable derek
jacobi who I've already had the joy of
listening to as the war master and the
war master series one
I think series two is out now I got to
get my hands on he's so friggin good but
so he's playing this television writer
who was commissioned by Sydney Newman
and Verity Lambert although he mostly
work with Sydney Newman and this is all
fictionalized to write the scripts for
what was going to be Doctor Who but the
show never moved forward early bits were
scripted he was revising he was drafting
I never moved forward he got moved to
other work at the BBC he wrote a bunch
of episodes for a cop drama like a 60s
cop drama that he thinks incredibly
little of but has a pretty sizable
fanbase and it's by far the thing he's
best known for despite the fact of being
an award-winning winning playwright
before starting to write for the BBC so
what this story focuses on is an ageing
writer who believes himself better than
the work he is known for doesn't have a
lot of regard for the people who liked
the show that he is best known for
writing for has a very broken history
with his family is suffering from some
degree of dementia and failing mental
faculties and who can't get the ideas of
Doctor Who completely out of his head
and to try and explain how all this
plays out is incredibly difficult but
not
because it's hard to follow because
Robert Sherman really knows this medium
he knows how to transition stuff
seamlessly from one situation into
another transitioning with the same
voice actors now actually doing
something different just through the
audio medium and what I mean by that is
Derek Jacoby's character he will you
know he'll be talking with this head
nurse at the maybe not the head nurse
but the one who works with the most
often at this nursing home he's talking
about his writing and she leaves and
he's starting to think about revisions
and you know how he can alter and how to
make the story better and suddenly he
himself is the doctor talking to Susan
not about writing the story but being
the doctor and having adventures with
her and names keep popping up that the
the nurse who is Barbara right Ian
Chesterton was was a man that she that
she was engaged to at one point these
names keep popping up we meet Martin's
own son Philip who hates him and the ins
and outs of what we learn about why that
is both in terms of what Martin did that
made his son hate him but also the ways
in which Martin is projecting other
things about his life and faulting his
father for how things have turned out
for him
and that's incredibly well vows because
that could easily have gone either way
that could that could have read either
as he was that he was just too harsh on
this guy or that Martin was unredeemable
II a jerk or it could have read as this
adult son just refusing to move on and
blame me as dad for everything but it
balances everything really well and if
everybody here is so human and it is
it's heartbreaking at times for a
variety of reasons so first off
peek behind the curtain I mentioned this
before because it's come up
intermittently when I've talked about
reviews that touch on these kinds of
things
my grandfather had dementia towards the
end of his life
so things that are able to respectfully
but also realistically and properly
touch on the that kind of thing that
degradation of a mind and the
frustration of both being the person
whose mind is degrading and being
someone trying to interact with someone
who's who has that going on when that's
captured well it's I end up finding a
very stirring of a lot of stuff and this
did that which to me says it did it well
and in terms of the broken history and
the broken relationships that Martin has
with his son and how he is desperate to
try and have a relationship with his
grandson he actually has yet to even
meet and he often doesn't remember he
has he there's a line that he has
basically telling Phillip I screwed that
up it's too late let me meet my grandson
I have a ruin to that yet oh like
there's so much in that there is so much
blind foolish hope in that there is so
much unresolved guilt in that there's
there so much but even while it's
tackling these things about family and
dementia and damage done from parent to
child it's also tackling
the nature of the artist and their
thoughts about their own art how they
feel about what is or isn't liked about
what they did what they wish they were
remembered for the sacrifices they made
for their art and this does something
that I really really appreciated because
so often when you see or hear or read a
story about an artist basically
sacrificing or torpedoing their personal
or home or family life for the sake of
their art even in stories where that's
not portrayed is a good thing
there's still usually an amazing piece
of art that results from that what
happens to Martin is he abandons his you
know this is backstory he abandoned his
wife and his child in the belief that he
was sacrificing them to make great art
and he just never did he worked but he
never made that great art so his
sacrifice was for nothing but he was so
arrogant and so self certain that he was
going to be amazing that he thought so
little of being around and supporting
and offering his energies to people who
loved him and needed him because he
never doubted his own genius and the
moments of jacobi having these moments
of Revelation of looking back and
realizing who he is the kind of man that
he is and has been and continues to be
their often brief because the guy's mind
is so fractured he doesn't hold on to
these thoughts for very long but when
they hit you can even hear it in the
boat and the voice and the vocal
performance it's
it is tragic in a low-key way this this
is this is familial and artistic
melancholy made manifest and for all the
things I'm talking about this is all
done in an hour in one hour you have an
exploration of the arrogance of artists
the degradation of a mind the shattering
of a family the retreat into art as an
escape from whatever doesn't work the
clinging to the piece that never got
finished all of that touched on a port
line none of its vestigial all of it
into woven interlocked and delivering a
complete experience in an hour
like i'm stiii I'm at this point I'm
prepared to lump Robert Sherman in with
Peter s beagle and just be like the this
is not fair you're too good at this it's
like oh it's discouraging to even think
of boy I wonder if I could write
something like that like no I couldn't
this is ridiculous how friggin good this
is that's not fair no one's supposed to
be this good ah it's the kind of good
that made that like a simal with
artistic ambitions it actually makes me
angry it's it's not a traditional Doctor
Who story by any means it's not even
what you would normally think of as a
what-if story because it's not even
about Doctor Who as a character it's
about doctor who is a piece of art kind
of like that's in there but it's
ultimately about all these other things
I mentioned and is such a complete
experience it's not my favorite piece
for me I think that's still Holy Terror
it's gonna take a lot to knock Holy
Terror off that top spot doesn't mean
amongst other things Polly Taylor still
has a mild time favorite Doctor Who
quote would hang on
ah God sent this so it doesn't matter to
whom the cruelty is directed the cruelty
itself is wrong and that's the Holy
Terror and I have a hard time thinking
anything's ever gonna top that but man
Robert Sherman
stop being so good except don't because
I want more
that's Doctor Who unbound deadlines have
you heard it
what did you think of it have you heard
any other entries in the unbound cuz
it's the only one I've listened to so
far what are your thoughts on any of
this do you have a favorite piece from
Robert Sherman what's your favorite Big
Finish just does what I just subscribe
something like the most ridiculous thing
you've ever heard of whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do down there as well cuz
buttons links likes are a big help also
subscribe that helps to support me on
patreon that helps even more but there's
other links to check out below give them
a click or don't you don't have to
because at the end of the day you're the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
you